but i do recognize that not all cultures
belong on the same piece of land
do you agree with that the practices are
sometimes too different
whether the legal systems are the
treatment of women the treatment of gays
we don't all believe belonging the same
piece of land when you look at the
numbers that have come to europe
in the past few years we've taken in
a million people from the eu and on the
whole they have assimilated
um germany took in a million muslims
in their crisis two years ago the rates
of rape
robbery criminal damage have gone up
exponentially
and their prisons are now overflowing
with an alien culture and this is
happening all over europe in fact i've
written a book on it which i should get
out of my bag
my look she says
because trump when he came over he spoke
very plainly
about how african and islamic mass
illegal immigration to europe
was changing and killing our local
culture of course
and it was it's got the annotations at
the side it's called the
migrant crane migrant crime wave and
where can we publish this book
um it's on my website janice atkinson
dot co dot uk
and it has all the statistics that
actually the eu doesn't want you to see
it's got the prison populations now
austria a tiny weeny
country in the middle of um of europe
population very very small 54
of the inmates in their prison are from
overseas
they're the people that are committing
the crime the rapes and the criminal
damage and there's an exponential rise
in the prison populations across europe
and it is predominantly from a muslim
and north african
background now we're importing these as
you say these
alien cultures they have sharia law they
have laws that are very very different
to us they treat women in a very
different way
they behead gays and throw them off of
buildings so therefore when you suddenly
import these amounts of people and the
msm at the moment is saying oh well yeah
the um migrant numbers have gone down i
mean they've just
disappeared well they haven't actually
eu figures which i published a couple
weeks ago
show that there's still 6.6 million
people sitting in camps
in greece in spain and there's two and a
half million
that we're paying turkey to keep people
in basically
internment camps because that's what
they are at the moment
and although the routes have been
stopped coming through italy then
they're diverting when they're going
into spain because there's no
it isn't um spain had a conservative
government yeah the prime minister did
something very very stupid and the
government felt
but i think there was a conspiracy to
get the government to fall
so that they can install a puppet
socialist who's refused to have a
general election
and now he's welcome in the boat so the
boats are just literally going into
spain now
i was in spain a few weeks ago i went to
see the
um frontex operations which actually
weren't allowed to see because we're enf
and frontex is the
border force equivalent um throughout
the eu and we all paid
towards that we weren't allowed to meet
the border force people front text but
we did go and see the guardians
who are the spanish so it's
semi-military so they're police but
they're also um semi-military they carry
guns and everything
and they're carrying out the border
force provisions in the south of spain
and they said last year they had 20 000
migrants that came through
this year they're expecting 40 000 and
that was after that was before
a spanish government fell and salvini
stopped the roots going into
italy and also the socialist maltese
government stopped
going into water so i can expect we can
i think expect a sudden surge to go
into spain and the spanish figures crime
figures are now rising and these
migrants are disappearing
um and they're and they're headed north
they're headed to branch germany
britain and the nordic countries and the
nordic countries
president trump said have we got any
problems in sweden
last night in sweden and we proved him
wrong because
there has been again an exponential rise
of
attacks in sweden and across and in
greece
the foreign prison population is
enormous the same in germany
and the list goes on and austria and
italy and we can't cope with this
our prisoners can't cope with that our
women should not be able to quote fair
and if you're gay why should you have to
put up with this barbaric a medieval
attitude
and what i would say to people if you
don't like our
liberal freedoms of speech our way of
life our culture and identity come here
and assimilate until that happens we
have to stop
all islamic immigration into our
countries
let's let's integrate make them
integrate into our countries as
as certain other countries are doing
across the eu and in hungary and poland
they have refused to have a migrant
quota from these
people that are sitting in these
internment camps around them and i don't
blame them
and they have got one of the most
peaceful societies
and it is no it isn't
um it isn't a rocket science to link the
crimes and everything that's happening
at the moment
with with the um
migrant flow that we've had and so until
such time we can actually cope
with integration we've got big problems
in this country of
pakistani grooming banks i mean there
may be up to a million girls that have
been affected by this
and i feel very very fronted and it's
not just the past 16
20 years this has been going on for
decades since they first arrived
until we get to grips with that problem
there should be no more but am i
am i anti-immigration absolutely not i
want the best
and brightest from around the world we
need nuclear scientists because we've
not been training our own kids
we need really clever kids from india
china
who are mathematicians computer
scientists
nuclear scientists those are the people
that we need and
if you add to our gdp come if you can
pay your own school fees
come if you can rent in private
accommodation
basically if you can come here and
contribute to our gdp
bring your family then you're very
welcome and
we will also look at genuine asylum
seekers but 80
to 85 percent of the people that are
coming into our shores
are economic migrant young men who have
all left their women and children behind
because they think they get through our
borders and then they can get their
family but it's not just one two three
four
five it's 10 15 it's the extended family
and that has to stop